philipp einerseits zeichnete die
bundesregierung und auch der expertenrat
ja einen
katastrophenszenario andererseits sind
die maßnahmen die da jetzt verabschiedet
wurden verglichen zu diesem szenario ja
eigentlich relativ
harmlos das lka hat deshalb gestern
gewarnt die maßnahmen müssten sofort
eintreten und zwar noch schärfere wer
hat recht tja die frage wer recht haben
wird die wird uns glaube ich erst die
zeit beantworten fakt ist aber dass die
bundesregierung und zwar auch
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach sich wirklich massiv gestört
fühlen vom rk ii und vom lkw chef lothar
wieler denn videos gesagt hast am
sonntag kam der expertenrat zusammen hat
ein papier veröffentlicht hat es an olaf
scholz persönlich geschickt und gesagt
wir empfehlen kontakt beschränkung in
diesem expertenrat sitzt auch lothar
wieler der präsident des robert koch
instituts und plötzlich ohne sich mit
jemandem abzusprechen offenbar hat er am
montag ein ganz eigenes papier vorgelegt
und noch viel weitreichendere maßnahmen
veröffentlicht und deswegen ist das
wirklich eskaliert gestern bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sowohl olaf
scholz als auch karl lauterbach haben
klargestellt für uns ist der experten
raten die empfehlung des expertenrats
bindend nicht das was das lka
veröffentlicht hat karl lauterbach hat
sich besonders deutlich distanziert hat
gesagt das war nicht abgesprochen
das ist chaotisch und das dürfe sich
auch nicht mehr wiederholen also das war
eine ziemliche watsch'n für herrn villa
der kommt jetzt immer stärker unter
druck und es ist nach wie vor nicht klar
warum er denn dieses papier
selbstständig veröffentlicht hat wo er
doch mitglied des expertenrats ist und
auch da schon hätte sagen können wenn
ihm das denn nicht weit genug geht
achtung wir müssen hier nachschärfen das
hat er nicht getan er hat selbstständig
ein papier veröffentlicht und damit auch
ehrlich gesagt die bevölkerung
verunsichert jetzt wurde mit
dem zweck gegründet diese verunsicherung
einzudämmen also das gefühl überall
melden sich experten zu wort geben ihre
meinung ihre einschätzung zur lage ab
und am ende wissen die bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht mehr woran sie sind das war
das erklärte ziel von olaf scholz wie
sehr glaubst du dieses ziel in den
nächsten wochen in den nächsten monaten
noch halten denn die idee muss man sagen
ist eine gute wir bringen die experten
an einen tisch jedoch herrscht ganz
offenbar doch keine einigkeit und es ist
so wie es von vielen mpk es gewohnt sind
jeder scheint irgendwie auch in diesem
fall nicht die bundesländer sondern die
experten ja das ziel war ein wirklich
gutes das ziel war ja auch sich breiter
beraten zu lassen die vorgängerin von
olaf scholz bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel hat ja kein festes
beratungsgremium sondern sie hat sich
ihre lieblings virologen immer zu sich
geholt in ihren hinterzimmer runden
etwas beraten man wusste auch nie genau
wer sie berät man wusste von einigen
beispielsweise von christian drosten der
sehr oft an ihrer seite war und genau
das wollte olaf scholz ändern und er
wollte aus verschiedenen lagern
sozusagen sich rat holen also neben
christian drosten und viola priesemut
melanie brinkmann ist beispielsweise
auch hendrik strick in diesem gremium
oder der kinderarzt berner aus dresden
wir sind wirklich wichtige stimmen und
das ist ein großer erfolg dass man
andere stimmen absolut das ist ein
großer erfolg dass man diese in einem
gremium zusammen geführt hat und dieses
gremium ja auch einstimmig 19 von 19
haben zugestimmt dieses papier
veröffentlicht hat und natürlich wenn
man jetzt einzelnen interviews führt mit
christian drosten oder mit hendrik
strikt wird es auch weiter schiedlich
unterschieden zumindest in deren
unterschiedliche meinungen geben das ist
auch völlig okay aber dass lothar wieler
chef des robert koch instituts am
sonntag einem papier zustimmt und das im
prinzip am montag für makulatur erklärt
in dem er sein eigenes papier mit viel
weitreichendere maßnahmen vorschlägt
dass offenbar auch mit niemandem
abgestimmt war das untergräbt natürlich
genau dieses ziel dass man eine expertin
kommunikation hat deswegen hat olaf
scholz gestern bei der pressekonferenz
auch offen klar gestellt für mich ist
der expertenrat bindend und das heißt
nicht dass was das robert koch institut
veröffentlicht karl lauterbach hatte
auch angekündigt darüber wird zu reden
sein ich weiß nicht wie weit man das als
konsequenzen die da lothar wieder
drohend interpretieren kann 12.30 heute
werden beide zusammen eine
pressekonferenz geben natürlich hier bei
bild live zu sehen was ist da zu
erwarten also es ist ehrlich gesagt seit
monaten schon bekannt dass lothar wieler
ein etwas angespanntes verhältnis hatte
auch schon mit dem vorgänger von
carlotta mit jens spahn man hat das bei
einzelnen pressekonferenzen gesehen wo
sich die beiden in den tonarten sehr
deutlich unterschieden haben und wir
haben auch aus internen runden gehört da
hat es oft öfter mal gekracht da gab es
nicht dieses vertrauensverhältnis was
optimal gewesen wäre in der prämie und
das scheint jetzt wirklich nahtlos
weiter zu gehen jens spahn hat lothar
wieler nie öffentlich kritisiert karl
lauterbach hat gestern wirklich
ausgeholt und in einer runde mit
ministerpräsident mit dem kanzleramt mit
dem bundeskanzler olaf scholz zu
erklären dass dass er das papier für
falsch hält das motto wieder
veröffentlicht hat dass er das ja das
nicht mit ihm abgesprochen war und dass
sich das nicht wiederholen dürfen auch
konsequenzen haben muss darüber zu
sprechen sein wird das ist schon ein
ziemlicher frau man muss ja auch sagen
dass rk ii ist eine nachgeordnete
bundesbehörde sie ist unterstellt dem
gesundheitsministerium von karl
lauterbach und wenn karl lauterbach
seine arbeit auf seine arbeit mit dem
expertenrat untergraben sieht von lothar
wieler dann wird eher handeln müssen was
ist konkret
inhaltlich von dieser pressekonferenz um
12.30 heute nochmal zu erwarten nachdem
jährigen gestern im corona gipfeln und
sie alle beschlüsse mitgeteilt worden
sind von olaf scholz ich glaube das
wichtigste ist der ausblick auf die
nächsten wochen
niemand kann ja sagen wie sich die
pandemie entwickelt es gibt
modellberechnungen die
modellberechnungen des expertenrats
wurden von der bundesregierung leider
noch nicht öffentlich gemacht werden als
verschlusssache behandelt wir haben auch
gestern angefragt haben gesagt gebt uns
doch bitte die modellrechnung heraus auf
denen die maßnahmen bewohnt haben sie
sagen das ist vertraulich also ehrlich
gesagt das ist ein absolutes unding und
ich glaube das wird sich auch noch
klären in den nächsten tagen aber das
wichtigste die wichtigste frage für
deutschland ist welche daten werden wir
überhaupt haben in den nächsten wochen
um zu bewerten wo wir denn stehen in der
pandemie denn wir wissen ja da wird
gerne mal urlaub gemacht in den
gesundheitsämtern die leute lassen sich
auch deutlich weniger testen
deswegen kann es wieder sein dass wir
genau wie letztes jahr einfach so eine
instanz loch haben werden dass
möglicherweise über wochen hinweg sich
ziehen wird das war im vergangenen jahr
ganz genau so hat man anfang januar
gesagt noch können wir gar nicht sagen
wo wir in japan wie stehen weil wir die
ganzen zahlen ja noch gar nicht haben
deswegen brauchen wir heute orientierung
für die nächsten wochen und ich erwarte
eigentlich die antwort auf die frage
nach welchen daten werden wir uns
ausrichten also wann entscheiden wir ob
die maßnahmen ausreichen ob wir sie
verschärfen müssen oder ob sie
vielleicht auch zu hart sind und die
pandemie die um mikrowelle doch nicht so
bedrohlich einschlägt wie erwartet all
das erwarte ich heute eigentlich
antworten und am 17 januar wird dann die
nächsten ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
sozusagen eine erste bilanz ziehen
vielen dank für den besuch